hi i'm charlie 10 a professor of
chemistry at the university of waterloo
it's my great pleasure to be here to
share my
research activities to develop
affordable and available magic
devices through a nanotechnology
approach
i'd like to thank dr eep and organizers
for this invitation
lab roots is certainly a new domain for
me as a scientist
with a background in material chemistry
i'm hoping that
my talk will bring some new perspectives
to lab roots as well
our healthcare system is going through
a transition from centralized to a more
distributed model
telemedicine e-health remote patient
monitoring etc
are at the forefront of this transition
internet and unprecedented capability
to collect process store and
sharing data our patient can access
certain health care nowadays
remotely whereas still at the early
stage of this transition
a lot of challenges remain today i'm
going to highlight just one challenge
which is remote testing when a patient
goes to hospital
he or she is not only there to see the
doctor
they are also there to access trained
professionals
central testing labs to get broadcast
done
urine testing so that objective evidence
can be gathered to assist diagnosis
to have the same quality of health care
offered through telemedicine
to enable remote patient monitoring we
must
have remote testing capabilities
on the left hand side here a few
parameters
that are already accessible nowadays
with the smart watch we can record
pulse we can record blood pressure
and for diabetic patients with a glucose
meter at home
they can measure blood glucose level but
for a lot other diseases like vascular
diseases the challenge is that
the biomarkers are at such low level
remote testing is still beyond rich
so the challenge to magical device
researchers
is to develop protools
to generate test results in outpatient
settings
without trained professionals without
central testing equipment
but with equivalent diagnostic values
to the physician now the research
activities
in my lab is essentially to
integrate intelligent materials and
devices
into portable and available systems for
point-of-care testing
so that we can address the need for
remote testing
at the core of our research are nano
carbon materials
namely carbon nanotubes graphene
they have exceptional physical and
chemical properties
and we develop chemistry for material
synthesis
for material functionalization for
forming
composites between bipolars and
functional nanocarbon materials to
impart biofunctionality
and further incorporate those materials
into devices through fabrication
processes
and the devices for example can be body
sensors
in array formats and it can be numbering
electrochemical sensors can be
incorporated into micro and nanophotic
devices
we've done a lot of proof of concepts
in the past and we're doing more
system integration to go beyond proof of
concept
so that prototype systems can be
delivered
to clinical researchers that those
system can be tested
in the real world i'm going to focus on
project number one
which is to turn our nanobiosensors
into handheld point of care broadcasting
systems
for chronic disease patient management
especially for heart failure
heart failure is highly prevalent
globally
one in five canadians develop heart
feeling during his or her
lifetime the number is going to rise
46 by 2030
the rate of hospitalization and the
re-hospitalization
of heart failure patients are extremely
high
traditionally when a patient experiences
symptoms
the patient goes to emergency room where
the first
broadcast can be done either discharged
or hospitalized and even after treatment
in hospitals the patients often get
rehospitalized
within 30 days our goal is to develop
knee issues devices they can enable
testing
in outpatient settings to break this
traditional route
so that the patient can receive
treatment much earlier receive diagnosis
much
earlier and also use it as a monitoring
device
to guide management at home
our system is called nanobots
it's a system solution integrates
nanobio sensors microelectronics
and also analytic chemistry method and
showing here is a prototype a second
generation
prototype system with a electronic
reader about the same size as iphone 6
or about half with
disposable tester strips that can be
plugged in
to the reader and use the four
fingerprint
rather test the goal is to
provide fingerprint block testing of b
type naturoratic peptide level
for early diagnosis and monitoring and
this whole device
operates very similarly to glucose meter
there are great similarities in this
design
similar to diabetes heart failure cannot
be cured
so patients have to manage
heart failure through a combination of
medicine
and lifestyle changes and
similar to glucose blood glucose
we're hoping that bnp can be the
biomarker
for heart failure diagnosis and
management
bmp is a established marker for
heart failure with well-understood
correlation between the severity of
heart beating
and the broad bmp levels on the picogram
per mole
premier level now the challenge is that
unlike glucose which is high
concentration in blood
bnb concentration is nine orders
lower so that nanobiosensors
with exceptionally high sensitivity
must be developed to meet this challenge
now what is a biosensor
uh it consists of three main components
in our case the biological recognition
element
is the antibody that specifically binds
to bnp
and the second component is a detection
detector element of the transducer in
our case
it's a carbon atomic thin that
translates the binding of
underbody and the bnp into electric
signals and the third part is the
electronic grid device i just showed you
that can read out this electric signal
and process and generate a meaningful
bmp
concentration level
the core technology the array of
nanobiosensors
implemented on the test strip
the immediateization of the
electrochemical spectrometer
into a handheld device and
algorithms for
incorporation of analytic
chemical methods and also machine
learning
let's look deeper in the composition of
the fabrication process
of the nanobiosensors as i mentioned
the transducer in our nanobiosensor
is the carbonarity of the same field a
challenge to nanobiosensor is the
reproducibility
how to produce high quality nano fumes
reliably and using a scale upper process
onto a low-cost substrate
is highly challenging and the process we
developed will meet this requirement
address those challenges it starts with
silica particles that are loaded with
catalysts
which are transitional metals like
cobalt and ion
and as you can see that after chemical
liquid deposition which is a process
the nanotubes grew out of them each
nanotube has a diameter
at one to two nanometers
and these nanotubes growing out of the
seeds which are the cathodes
and we further develop with the transfer
process
they cleanse up this analogy
as shown here and also allow
us to transfer this onto a plastic
across certain type of the low-cost
substrates
this is the actual uh system for the
sensor cells
this is a low pressure chemical vehicle
deposition system
this is not unique to nanotube synthesis
as a matter of fact this is commonly
used in
the semiconductor industry therefore
the synthesis process we have is
readily scale uppable and it provides
uniform in terms of thickness and
purity in our nano tube thin film and is
highly reproducible
here choose the uh transfer process
on the upper left corner it's a six inch
wafer with a carbon cube thinking
already growing on it
the raman spectroscopy was used
to examine the quality the the peak over
here
indicate high purity carbonation on
the silicon substrate by
the transfer process we have this
subfume
can be lifted and then deposited as a
whole
onto a plastic substrate
with patent uh goldilocks
and therefore each thin film each
refreshing film
can be made into an array of 50
to 200 sensory devices
the principle of operation for the
nanobiosensors
is that the binding of bmp
with antibody on the surface of
commonality
modulates the conductivity of the
carbonation
and therefore the overall resistance
of the nanotube same view by
reading recording the electric impedance
of the sensory device at various
frequencies
a technique called electric impedance
spectroscopy
as plotted here the nyquist plot of
one representative spectrum we were able
to
extract the resistance of the cnt film
which is nearly correlated to bnp
concentration in the test
sample and these
are the atomic force microscopy
imaging of the narratives and field
those are the bell centers clean and
smooth and you can see the decoration
of proteins along the tube lines
those are the antibodies and the bmps
that bonding on the surface
and the bonding on the surface model is
the conductivity
and therefore more bmp enterprising on
the surface
the higher overall cnt thinking
resistance
it will be
those are test results on the left hand
side
are electrical impedance
uh spectrum collected at various time
points
uh of the same nanobiosensor
the black squares are collected
when the nanotube thin film is clean and
later spectrums are after underbody
functionalization after blocking
functionalization and at a certain
time points zero minutes five minutes
after 30 minutes
after the exposure of the bionic sensors
to a bmp solution on the right hand side
of plotting of the rcnts
extracted from this spectrum on the
spectra on the left
and you can see that the property of
rcnt
which is correlated to surface
binding of emp is an isothermal plot
with saturation after 15 minutes which
means
within 15 minutes we can
readily quantitatively detect bnp
concentration
with rc and t values
here is the comparison between the
performance of our nanobot system
to go to standard immune verizon's assay
as mentioned the nanobot system takes
use one antibody as the capture
or the um recognition element on the
carbon nitrous
surface the body of bmp to this antibody
translates to the change in rcnt
and in immunofluorescence essay a pair
of antibody must be used
one is the red on the body for capture
and
second is the reporter antibody
which is typically labeled with a
fluorophore
to report the capturing of
the target molecule bmp and
here it shows the correlation between
these two
methods which is excellent
the advantages of the noun process done
that
by using one single tac-free antibody
the cost is going to be dramatic lower
and the second
it has a much simplified procedure it's
a one-step
real-time detection no wash is needed
because the trust use the knowledge
only responds to service money and
disregard the the bmp presented in the
solution
and in comparison in conscious
immunofluorescence assets cannot
distinguish
between the forward force in the
solution versus one type bond
on the surface and therefore a thyroid
washing must be done prior to uh
detection
a third advantage is that
by using analytical chemical methods
the system can do self-calibration uh
unlike these standard immunofluorescence
i say
that external calibration must be done
prior to each quantitative detection
now here is a comparison between the
performance
of a nanopart system with a commercial
emergency room handheld
system and again
the commercial system requires a pair
of antibodies the report on the body
usually is labeled with an enzyme
that can use enzymatic process
to amplify signal and for nanopart
because the nanosensors
are so sensitive that no amplification
is needed and also
the nanobot only need one drop of blood
that's less than 100 microliters
and in comparison the commercial
emergency room
reader needs 250 microliter or more
and therefore venous part must be drawn
and here shows the correlation between
these
two detection methods on 28
patient-derived plasma samples
so far i've focused on one particular
system that can specifically detect
one biomarker in blood for heart failure
patients
over the past 15 years though
nanobiosensors have demonstrated the
capability
to detect a wide range of targets
virus bacterial dna other protein
biomarkers
um in not only blood and also other
body fluids um so i would like to wrap
up my presentation
by giving you the big picture a
nanobiosensor platforms
can potentially offer solutions
to a lot of technical communications
for this highly connected world
and finally i would like to thank
my students and my colleagues for their
hard work
and also the financial support provided
by various funding agencies
and thank you for your attention